[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I am shout out them from instacart I
will be talking about some of the
lessons we learned from how we integrate
machine learning models into production
into basically our product
so my experience prior to this I worked
in search and recommendations and at
targeting last 10 or DEA's at various
places now I lead the search and
discovery team instacart it's a product
team so cross-functional product team
with engineers designers today
scientists analyst so how many here have
heard of instacart before Ian just
mentioned ok and how many in place in
order ok how many you got really a bad
replacement like a cucumber with a
zucchini that's probably my mistake
sorry Bella so yeah so InfraGard is an
on-demand grocery delivery service so
essentially we don't have very houses we
deliver from stores that you already
know that you otherwise shop from and
the because there's a customer app you
you select the store you add groceries
you place an order and that could you
know get get to your place and as you
know as little as an hour my personal
record is like 37 minutes kind of
amazing there's a shop or an app which
is an entirely different thing and this
is a case where people sign up to be
shoppers they walk into the store and
you know they have their you know
they're scheduled to be in the store at
a certain time based on how we can
estimate demand from that store you know
at that sort of a at that hour and so
they're already in the store they accept
your order they shop for your items and
they potentially communicate with you
through the app if they have a
clarification and and then they deliver
it at your door so that's that's sort of
the model and if you think about the
players here there are customers people
placing orders are there are shoppers
those in the store then they're the
retailer's themselves like Whole Foods
and safety of the world and then there
are the advertisers or you know product
people who basically build the product
but as if our time involved things like
a box of cereal right so brands Radha so
these are the four players there is like
a fourth set of marketplace and any of
these interactions between
these players is sort of ripe for an
opportunity to build a data product
right matching you know they're multiple
workflows for each of these players and
there are places you can optimize so
they're plenty of different problems to
work on
so that's just the context to that you
know that's true we can move into like
what I'm talking about in terms of more
general experience based on what we saw
there right so you could imagine that in
these in the beginning that was you know
if you think about when you start off a
company you're probably a solving the
most important problem for the customer
or you know you're doing it anyway but
even say within you know data scientists
or in the data science team you're
picking one problem trying to solve that
in the easiest possible way so think
about how that architecture is going to
be you probably have like one production
database for pretty much everything and
you know you have you're pulling data
from that you're creating a training
data
you're building a model and you're
writing the model back to you know your
database either a location of a file or
the model itself if it's a bunch of
coefficients you're running it in the
database right so that's literally the
first ever sort of training pipeline and
then the test pipeline our scoring
pipeline is essentially sort of similar
you do pretty much the exact same thing
except instead of training the model you
were scoring examples and you write back
your predictions to the database and you
use them or maybe you score it in real
time which is which also happens but
probably not often the case so what you
have here is a very simple case where
like the training and the scoring is
essentially identical all right the same
code path and so it's like kind of low
risk but you can't do that forever and
you can't do that well you can do that
as long as that's you have like one
problem and scale is not an issue or you
know there's no
micro-services that need to worry about
all you have to do is you know just
write to the database and recon the
database so it's a simple architecture
and SLA is are not a thing either right
so that's that's probably the first ever
thing somebody bills but but eventually
those models get like the product gets
more complicated right you get product
markets it
you have scale you can you know SLA is
matter and you know you can't imagine
there's so many things happening in the
app and there's one model that you have
you can't afford to bring down the
entire app because it's that one model
right and so things that work only have
one model doesn't work when you move on
to other models and so what you get is
you have to find a way to think about
okay how do I now change the way machine
learning is done when I go from one
model to more models and these are
subtle issues of you experience and you
just have an example you know going over
you know a few different things that we
do right so you land on the storefront
you over an app is going to load the app
up or on the web you land on the
storefront as as instacart we
personalize your experience on the site
which means what what sort of
departments to share what products to
show what we're ranking do they appear
as you can imagine grocery is very
different from regular ecommerce where
you know there's in grocery to think
about buying things over and over again
so the combination of recurring
orders and and then there's also
discovery so how do you bounce these -
how do you present products and product
categories on your storefront that is
one problem another one which I guess
every site has a search how do you rank
search products in response to a query
another one might be like I mentioned
replacements one unique thing about the
way we do on-demand delivery is we are
picking from stores that are not our
inventory right we these are not our
warehouses and also these are stores
where anybody else is going in
taking the same things from so if let's
say you place an order you know for a
bag of chips to be delivered tomorrow
evening when when when the shopper goes
to the store we don't know if those bag
of chips will actually be there for sure
there is a chance it's not there and we
want to prepare the customers for it so
one problem is how do you recommend
substitute products for the customer the
other is well you know a typical grocery
you think of a family of four and easily
somebody's ordering weekly is probably
adding like a couple of dozen things to
the cart so how fast you can keep the
shopping going matters otherwise you've
got to have like think about if you have
at 24 things to the cart and you have to
evaluate at least two things before you
add one you're essentially spending
easily a or an hour building your cart
which is sort of a very unusual line so
speeding that up which means like
recommending the next thing that you
might be interested if you if you add a
bag of chips
we probably recommend you salsa but if
you what's also you know a last order we
probably don't want to do that right so
recommending the next item is another
problem so now these are experiences
that are sort of peppered throughout the
product and each of these things are you
know complex and how do you integrate
that without you know hurting the core
user experience these are some of the
problems that you know we've had to work
with so what that means is it changes
how we go from you know one model to
like probably we in a couple of dozen
different data products so one thing we
try to look at when evaluating what how
should it model be integrating dual
customer workflow is think of like the
response time latency or response times
what what can people tolerate for this
particular experience and that's really
depend on the on the product itself it's
certainly dependent customers I'm sure
some people you know are more impatient
others but generally at a product level
think about let's say web search
web search needs to people
essentially expect like sub second to
latency but I think about travel search
right people easy just easily sort of
tolerate more than you know five ten
seconds and I don't know in the last ten
years if travel such as gotten any
faster it's almost like customers are
anchored to that experience and you know
if you're building a search engine
optimization or search engine ranking at
a travel search company
you're better off investing any latency
benefits into improving the ranking
itself because you know that people you
know just because you make it four and a
half seconds maybe maybe people don't
actually carry that much but there are
the places you know let's say value loan
applications where it might take even
more in a wait like half a minute before
you're told okay you know this is your
interest rate you're accepted or
otherwise so in general I feel like what
we've seen like if if there is a high
payoff and if there's a one-off
interaction then you can afford more
delays compared to if it's like several
you know page loads before you do
something so building a card has to be
really fast time so that's the latency
aspect right
second thing is context sensitivity so
the question that is like how much
information do you need to make that
decision
how much context you need how much does
more recent data matter and you could
think of extremes where you every single
input is independent of that other input
let's say it doing
I'll think about this problem where you
know we are ingesting data from
retailers and we have to look at a
product you know if it's in the catalog
fine great we get it already gets match
to something that's already there but if
it's not then you're matching you
probably have to do a bunch of things
like okay what categories is this
product the long term it's a
hypothetical example right so this is
not that context-sensitive you look at a
document you have to make like a text
categorization decision this is like
produce or this is like shampoo so on
right so some problems don't bet
from context do you think about like how
much do you benefit from more recent
data that's like one more place that
really changes the way the models
interact with your product and how you
architect your model itself so one sort
of clever thing you can do is change the
product experience so that you you sort
of buy more time to score say you need
to score you need more data to score ask
more and more empower information first
I'll keep predicting in the background
like what's your best guess so that
you're always ready to you know present
that decision so so there are ways to
sort of buy time to get more context so
there's the latency and then there's you
know context sensitivity and if you put
that in a quadrant which you know you
would see essentially you'd have you
know four different combinations with a
low latency you know highly
context-sensitive
and you know the other three
combinations and one question we ask is
like where does what we want to do
belong right think of this example where
if something is very high now low
latency requirement and it is context
sensitive an example might be search
ranking where you really cannot cache
things how to be really fast sub-second
it benefits some more recent data so
that could be you know one example
really strict essays the other extreme
is you know like our first example for
latency is not a big deal and there's no
context sensitivity right these are like
a lot of plastic recommendation systems
where your training unlike several
months of user behavior and you're
scoring essentially in the same pipeline
instantaneous scoring and you can score
it and you can cache it and you can
serve it so he's even though serving
latency is not very high but scoring
could be as high as you want because it
it really doesn't matter there's no
context so that gives you like these two
extremes and then well the other two
which is you know low latency and
are no contest required and we've seen
this for example with think about the
thing about like the customer expects
things to be really fast but the
decision can be made without a lot of
past data this is the case with say when
you have a long tail of inputs and
inputs are sort of unpredictable and you
cannot really cache except in the head
but the tail is long right but it has to
be fast so that's one example would be
in our in a experience like if you're
ranking search the first level of
matching for search the tf-idf for B m25
like simple elasticsearch calls that
sort of sort of fall in this category
and we have some of those as well and
finally my favorite is when latency is
well the Taconic sensitive but latency
isn't such a big deal and that is where
you know the example exam imagine that
you're building your card you adding
potentially 10 things gear card and each
time you add things to the card that
something in the background that is
scoring you know for some outcome it
keeps scoring it always keeps a best
estimate of you know whatever it's
trying to estimate maybe it's you know
what should I recommend you a check out
some impulse purchase making up an
example and it's doing that all the time
right and when whenever you ask for a
response you get it right so this is
where the latency of scoring doesn't
matter because the scoring is happening
in the background but the context
matters because well context helps for
that task so you want to use as much
data as possible
in the extreme case you might think well
everything has to be like low latency
and context sensitive right that's where
you you you consolidated data you have
or you can get and everything is super
fast but everything doesn't have to be
that way right so in our case for
example
so the the question we ask is you know
well you want to be in sort of the first
quadrant you want to be low let it later
low latency chronic sensitive but can
you start somewhere else because that's
one of the hardest places to be so can
you start by being in you know low
latency sorry height now reasonable
agency and no context so you start from
let's say four and three in that case
right and which means that you were
doing as much as possible in batch mode
and you've caching things can you start
there and then can you move to you know
high context and in a reasonable latency
through Quadrant two and and then
eventually you get a quadrant one right
where does your problem belong and where
you know where does it eventually need
to be from the custom point of view and
where can you start
so recommendation is an example where
you can start off with reasonably good
recommendations by just you know bad
scoring in the back by now in a batch
mode so that simplifies how you do mine
how we do training and how we do scoring
you can then move to scoring in the
background with context but latency is
still you know you're still willing to
live with latency because you're scoring
in the background based on most recent
information so you go from quadrant
three to two and you land up in one for
some problems you can't be in Quadrant
three at all because you know you can't
actually have a high latency a solution
for that so you might actually start in
Quadrant four where you know the
simplest thing is well you respect the
latency but you don't really necessarily
use a lot of context and see what you
can score with that start from q4 and
then you move towards you know the ideal
place for that problem you know which is
low latency and high high context and
this sort of a third as well where you
know we start off a data product in in a
place that we can you know the Gophers
very often is too
set up that workflow both on the back
end on the front end you know these are
discussions we have with data engineers
because it has implications for logging
and your aggregations and also it's
going to have a product engineers
because they are the ones that are
consuming our output and you know very
often you know they would push for sort
of attention like we want the models to
be as accurate as possible but we don't
want to stress other parts of either the
infrastructure or other parts of the
consumer experience so the sort of
framework helps us think about where
where we want to be or where we want to
start and how do we actually get to
quadrant 1 if that makes sense ok so the
second thing that we saw which is
essentially outside of you know 1:1
levels of deeper is you know you have
one model that's where you've been for a
while now you have you know product
market fit and scale that are more
approach needs where a I or machine
learning matters predictive modeling
matters and so now you have more models
there are more models more features more
people building them and more people
duplicating things so so what I like to
think of is is there something you know
we talk about like economies of scale
where as you as you buy or as you as you
work on larger scales things become
either more cost-effective or easier to
do there's also the economies of scope
which is it's not so much about like how
many things you do but how many
different things you do if you have like
70 different models that are doing
somewhat related things and I said
related they probably share a good part
of the inputs so for any consumer
products say a user profile it's
something that's shared by something
that benefits many models and many
right so user profiles are things that
everybody wants and everybody has their
essentially their own view of what those
profiles should look like what should
you how should you encode a certain
feature our product profile the product
you know attributes product taxonomy
related attributes so that might be like
you know what is the average popularity
of this product in the last ten weeks so
these are features that are useful for
any number of models that we might build
and we realize we have to find a way to
share features across models and we want
to do that in a way that doesn't get in
the way of like productivity if anything
it helps iterate faster and it is also
sort of aligned with you know sort of
transfer learning wherein you learn
features are in a particular problem and
you're able to translate that use those
features in a related data set related
prediction problem so think about let's
say two specific examples if you're
trying to find a replacement we've
talked about this problem before trying
to what's a good replacement for a
Product X and what you trying to think
like you know what kind of features
matter some kind of match between the
product are no description that matters
certainly the price difference matters
you know is it the same brand is it
organic are they both organic are they
both the same brand that sort of matters
also some kind of affinity right even
independent of the source product
how much does somebody a particular user
the personalization component how much
does a user like you know this
particular brand that matters right now
think about a different problem like
ranking products for a particular query
for a particular user obviously the
match fitting the query and the product
matters and you know how often that the
user has bought that product before that
matters but also that same affinity that
we talked about you know how much does
this person like products like these
even if they haven't bought before
right so that's an example of a feature
that matters and two different problems
because really we're thinking about like
entities are interviewed at queries
brands customers products in the entire
catalog hierarchy what any sort of data
problem we take is some sort of
relationship between these two right if
you're trying to do ad targeting you're
trying to match users and brands if
you're trying to do personalization your
matching users and products if you're
doing related products it's a pair of
products if you try to do spell
correction it's a pair of queries right
so there are a lot of opportunities for
like sharing features across models and
one thing that we came up with is if you
think of the features themselves you
know there are some on-the-fly features
that you know that just have to be
computed I know is the item on sale
right now
you can't catch that right it just comes
as an attribute of the product there's
no need to do anything special at
scoring time it's available to all the
models on an equal footing and then
there are these aggregate features
features like you know how often do
these user by this brand product you
know in the last few months or how often
do people type in avocado and buy you
know something from personal care like
avocado flavored shampoo soap or
something I'm more likely to buy
something from Pretty's so these sort of
aggregate features right and then there
are features that are like learn
features learn representations that come
from you know you know deep models or
shallow models like ortho whack or not
even neural networks like you know Lda
vectors that you can compute for a user
you can you can have that being computed
in a pipeline and you can just have them
you know use the cross models no nobody
needs to think about you know writing
recomputing these features right so the
d3 had to be the features and the last
two you can cache or rather you can have
a centralized key value store that
allows us to use these features across
models and that's basically what we did
so what is the sort of key value store
need to do think about it as you know I
I I know that for a given model I need
to know that these are the list of
features I need I need
LD vectors for a user I need earlier
vectors for product what to expect is
for you know a user product and so on
and in aggregate features for users how
many time how often did a user buy a
certain product so you only need to say
what you need for a model and you should
just assume that you'll get it you'll
get it at training time you'll get it
that's you know scoring time because you
know that somebody is writing to it
writing those features to the key value
store all right so what this allows us
to do is not just share features but
also sort of maintain the sort of sacred
contract which is you know if and if you
see an observation and if you extract up
you know features for that in training
it should be the exact same as if you
extract features in scoring time that's
something that is sort of non-negotiable
with like feature extraction all right
but now since you're you know reading
features from the same key value store
that is automatically guaranteed and you
know you can there are other ways of
doing it right we could think of you
know you can lock feature that training
sorry at scoring you can because you're
scoring and use computing features you
can you can log them and then you can
use the same features at training time
so that's like one more way and Charlie
arguably the most robust way because you
know exactly what the feature was when
it was computed and scored but you had
to be careful that you know this will
not work if you have new features you
want to try new features you have to
recompute them in your training pipeline
so two things basically are achieved we
are able to share features and be able
to you know maintain the sort of second
contractors you know feature extraction
and just a very little bit about what
that one more level of detail right so
what do you need you need like a high
highly available key value store like
Cassandra you know dynamo that
essentially takes it only knows that
Mikey is a user product my value is
vector the key name has some semantics
or what the feature is right and the the
the how you extract feature or rather
how do you read features it's something
that the library takes care of you takes
care for you right because all it needs
to do is you know think about like you
have you need to be able to say that
this is a feature that I want and the
model when you specify the model at
scoring time it has all the features
aims and it it parses that to understand
that these are you know shared features
it is able to then extract these
features from the key value store and
then stitch them together in a data
frame which is now you know you can
combine that with other features that
you doing so all you have to think about
is for this model what are the right
what are the unique features that are
specific to this model and what are the
features that are you know shared
features and that significally
simplifies whatever you know whatever
the task is so now we have simple
example as you know you ha you have
features to compute a replacement for a
product I imagine you have another task
where I need to compute let's say is
this product a new version of the other
product or a size we're into the other
product which is useful you could you
can pretty much run with the same
features and the few extra features and
you're able to spin up a model so that
sort of we've that's the pattern that
we've seen and you know we have this
running right now in production for like
three different models you know which
sort of in a sort of similar tasks that
have like fair amount of shared features
and that's that's worked well so that's
what I have